obviously you and tiger recorded this
together Wayne getting involved where's
the Wayne Uh do you send it out
obviously yes so
um we were just discussing different
features and my bro AK was like yo what
about Wayne and I was like yo that's
crazy I'm in Texas because I was like I
just wanted it to feel like I wanted
somebody goaty on it you feel like me
and tiger cool like I want somebody if
we do a third person it got to be
something like I could go yeah gotta be
a goat and then so I text Wayne I said
it to him and he sent it back like
four or five days and it was up from
there that's a great turnaround yeah I
don't think he like I think he he's just
so he impossible with this like you
can he's just I don't even think he
write his lyrics now he just goes he's
one of them guys was this a swapper did
you have to pay Wayne how does that work
man you know because this is his
business but it's also love involved you
feel me so he could use you in the
Carter 17 or whatever
I'd be down for sure we're waiting on
the Carter six let's go carter finals
shout out to Weezy man